Let's take a look at something cool.
Today, we're going to integrate Komodor
with vCluster.
What is vCluster?
VCluster is a tool from Loft
that allows you to have ephemeral
or potentially
ephemeral
clusters
inside
of another Kubernetes cluster. It does this by
running a control plane and save a namespace
on Kubernetes
to give you a complete virtual cluster, hence
the name vCluster
inside the host cluster.
There are a lot of advantages to this
approach.
It allows you to operate and maintain a
slightly larger cluster,
but delegate virtual clusters to all of your
teams, organizations,
or maybe even just micro services.
That means that it's very easy to delete
the virtual cluster,
spin up a new one and you have
pretty happy days.
Of course, you have to provision
those clusters, those still have to be debuggable,
you still need to understand when things go
wrong and this is where Komodor comes in.
So today, I'm going to show you how
to automatically deploy Komodor
to all of your virtual clusters.
We'll start off with the current landscape,
this is my real production scale away Kubernetes
cluster
which has access to six nodes.
Now these nodes aren't that heavily utilized, but
I want to open this up to members
of the Rawkode Academy community
and to do so, I'm going to get
them a virtual cluster,
but I still have to make sure those
clusters are healthy and to do that, I
100% need Komodor.
As you can see, I've run Komodor already
on my production cluster
and if we click on the cluster drop
down, you'll see that I only have Skidway
production.
Here I have a just file, this just
file has a simple target for deploying a
new virtual clusters with whatever name I give
it.
To do this, it uses helm upgrade
install
using the arguments provided to provide the cluster
name and also the values. Yaml.
Instead of our values. Yaml, we see that
we want all virtual clusters to be KCS,
here I'm just using version 123.5.
We can then use the init section of
the values file to say that we wish
to deploy some helm charts.
Here I'm specifying one chart and that's what
I want to deploy to Kubernetes workshop chart
from the Komodor LJOX repository.
I've hard coded my key here, but of
course you can find better ways to do
that through secret management or even interpolation of
the template.
I'm using values template here so that I
can also reference the release name as the
cluster name so that I can differentiate my
virtual clusters within Komodor.
Now we can just run
vCluster
Rawkode
and that should just take a few seconds.
And I'm gonna run it one more time
only this time we'll call it academy
one two three.
So with these two simple commands
on my production gateway cluster, I'm deploying two
virtual clusters,
both those virtual clusters are configured to automatically
deploy Komodor injecting the release name which happens
to be the cluster name.
What does mean is that when I browse
back to Komodor in just a few seconds,
we'll now have access
and observability,
debug ability, the ability to visualize and understand
the Kubernetes landscape of our virtual clusters.
Easy peasy.
Well, let's jump back and hit refresh
and we can see that the Rawkode cluster
is still available.
I'm gonna wait a few more seconds
for the academy cluster to also show up.
There we go. So now if we filter
to Rawkode,
we'll see version one twenty three point five
for the two nodes in that cluster
and if we switch to the academy,
we're still waiting on a node coming up
but that's okay.
We can then use Komodor just as we
always do. Here we can see the core
DNS and the watcher for the academy cluster
and if we switch to Rawkode,
we have to save there.
So let's deploy a broken workload to our
virtual cluster.
To do so, we do vCluster,
connect to Rawkode
in the default namespace
and kubectl apply
dash f nginx
dot yaml.
Easy.
So let's pop back over to Komodor and
already we can see our nginx deployment under
the pod workloads screen
and we can see that there's an error
pulling our image.
So if we click on this
and pop open the containers,
we'll see that the image being used is
NGINX
non existent.
Not really a typhoon,
but a common problem that we all have
to debug and one that Komodor solves with
ease.
Let's fix this to deploy NGINX one nineteen,
and we'll run our apply command one more
time.
And let's just watch from the Commodore UI.
We already see the new pod, we already
see its container creating
and now it's running.
So vCluster and Commodore work together just like
a charm.
Take advantage of ephemeral clusters within mega clusters,
but don't sacrifice your ability to operate each
of those clusters
as well. I hope you enjoyed this video.
We'll be back with more Komodor videos soon.
Have a good day.